today on the matt wall show big tech is
now hunting down and banning anyone who
accuses lgbt activists of grooming but
why aren't we allowed to say that well
because it's true also more fallout from
the bombshell report revealing that big
pharma has been lying for years
about the antidepressants that it sells
plus we'll check in on a local news
segment with an hr expert about the
correct approach to preferred pronouns
in the workplace and democrats in the
house passed the right to contraception
act codifying our alleged god-given
right to birth control and destroying
religious freedom not to mention common
sense in the process we'll talk about
all that and more today on the matt wall
show
[Music]
well i have some
unfortunate news for you today uh
abandoned shopping carts have attacked
my car you've never heard this story
before if you have i'll tell it again it
was only a matter of time i saw this
coming five years ago which prompted my
initial cancellation of people who don't
return their shopping carts to the
designated shopping cart areas and here
we are with rogue shopping carts
crashing into my car scratching my front
bumper totaling the car destroying my
life
and there are two lessons we can take
away from this one don't be lazy put
your shopping carts away so that i and
my car don't have to needlessly suffer
and number two most importantly
rockauto.com is the place to go when you
find yourself in this sort of situation
rockauto.com is an online family-owned
business that sells all the auto parts
you could ever need specific to your own
vehicle their prices are shockingly
reasonable and they ship fast their
website makes it incredibly easy to find
the right parts for your car with photos
specs and even installation tips
rockauto.com will not only have the part
but usually they'll give you several
trusted brands to choose from so you get
a big selection as well rock autos kits
are also popular because
they bundle together all the parts
needed for a successful repair you don't
get halfway through installing a timing
belt and discover that you need another
pulley or something like that so you go
to rockauto.com for your auto parts
needs today get everything you need
there and while you're there be sure to
use code walsh in their how did you hear
about us box so they know that i sent
you
a little while ago eric roman who's a
public school employee in mount pleasant
michigan attended a school board meeting
where he rose to the microphone donning
his black lives matter t-shirt
introduced himself as both lgbt and
fully vaccinated and then proceeded to
speak out against parents who opposed
the lgbt indoctrination of their
children he mocked and belittled them he
made fun of all of their uh concerns and
and he was quite quite proud of himself
too very proud of what he was saying and
thought that he was giving um quite a
rising speech as you can tell let's take
a look
i'm a resident county taxpayer
vaccinated and functioning
graduate of this high school class of
1999 proud member of the lgd
lgbtqia community and an employee of
mount pleasant public schools thank you
[Applause]
i really cannot speak any more
eloquently than the people who have
spoken before me tonight but what i can
say is that for the last five years i've
had the profound privilege
of working with your students
with your students
with your students
and i can tell you this
they are hungry for knowledge
they are so
hungry for knowledge
that despite your words
your wishes your
values
they will learn on their own
so many of your children are hurting
questioning
struggling in this world that we have
created
they are simultaneously being taught to
celebrate and to hate who they are i
can't deny that
every day
ultimately
they will become who they will become
with or without
us
give them the chance
the grace
and the support to embrace their own
learning they're gonna do it anyway
no matter what you say or do
kids are hungry for knowledge he says
and he's right you know kids are hungry
for knowledge they are but lgbt
indoctrination is not knowledge gender
fluidity is not knowledge
guys like him do not impart knowledge
any more than a scientology center
imparts knowledge
kids are hungry for knowledge indeed and
they leave our school system still
starving
for it
but according to a report in the
national file it seems eric roman was
hungry himself for something else the
report says
a michigan public school employee who
staunchly advocated for lgbt curricula
to his district school board
has been arrested as part of a police
sting operation targeting local
pedophiles 41 year old eric roman an
employee of mount pleasant
michigan's public school system was
arrested as part of an isabella county
sheriff's office sting operation that
also saw two more alleged child
predators put behind bars according to
local reports isabella county law
enforcement was assisted in the sting by
agents from the fbi and the michigan
state police among others along with two
other men eric roman 42 of mount
pleasant was arrested in an undisclosed
location all three were arrested for
using a computer to commit a crime and
accosting a minor for immoral purposes
police allege that three communicated
over various social media apps with
decoys posing as children the three are
accused of going to a location to have
sex with a child where they were
arrested the report goes on to explain
so this man um you just heard there in
that clip
doesn't like it when public school
employees are called groomers and in his
case
you know maybe he has a point he's not a
groomer he's already moved well beyond
the grooming stage
meanwhile another viral video shows a
second grade teacher bragging about
her class coming out
as gender fluid
and if that statement seems confusing
yes i mean what i said her entire class
of second graders came out all at once
she says
watch
so it took a couple days for me to make
this tick tock um
without crying because
that's what i do um please ignore the
dog bone crunching behind me anyhow um
one of my students uh felt safe enough
to share his pronouns with me
and
when he did so
once the class knew that i knew they all
switched pronouns
they're second graders
like i'm torn between being really
really happy to be a safe space
and just absolutely furious that an
entire group of second graders has to
keep this secret from not safe
people
why are kids feeling unsafe
and
furthermore why does everyone talk about
how how are the kids going to understand
the kids understand it
it's easy for them it's the adults who
have all of the
issues and
hang ups and bullsh
kids are fine
keep it a secret
from unsafe people she says
and the unsafe people of course being
the children's parents now
in a sane country just that video alone
and we've seen so many like it but just
that one would be a major scandal a big
story
i mean think about what she's just told
she says that her entire class of second
graders switched pronouns meaning that
they came out as trans or non-binary or
gender fluid or whatever other nonsense
the whole class
even if gender theory made sense which
it doesn't but if it did
does it predict or account for
classrooms of young children being lgbt
no nothing accounts for this except for
the truth which is that kids are being
groomed and recruited on a massive scale
and that assisting in this effort is a
social contagion effect so potent that
it can spread through whole classrooms
and schools
and generations at lightning speed
one more example breitbart
breitbart reports today the centers for
disease control is promoting to youth an
online chat space that discusses sex
polyamorous relationships the occult sex
change operations and activism and is
specifically designed to be quickly
hidden while being used it also mixes
lgbt adults and children and is run in
part by planned parenthood called q chat
space the platform is advertised on the
cdc's lgbt health youth resources page
the chat service which describes itself
as a community for lgbtq plus teens is
available for those ages 13 to 19 can be
hidden from parents
and focuses on a number of mature themes
q-chat hosts conversations on a number
of different mature and sexual topics
including drag culture 101 sex and
relationships and having multiple
genders intended for bipan youth cue
chat also features conversations on
gender affirmation surgeries as well as
on hormone replacement therapy
the chats are used in part to tell
children where you can find resources
related to their transition
now demonstrating just how
scientific gender theory is
this site also has lessons on astrology
and tarot cards
one is titled self-discovery in
astrology and another is called queering
tarot
because apparently tarot is not queer
enough already
the grooming conspiracy we see is vast
and far-reaching and though it focuses
especially on sexuality it does not
limit itself to that
the goal is to turn your child into a
disciple of their religion with fealty
to all of its tenants even the most
bizarre ones especially the most bizarre
ones
as these grooming efforts ramp up
then so too do the efforts to prevent
people
from talking about it
so last week a popular reddit forum
officially banned people from using the
word groomer
which i guess we now must call the the g
word
declaring that
uh the word groomer is homophobic and
it's anti gets a slur it's a homophobic
slur
soon leftist groups like media matters
we're calling on all other social media
platforms to ban the term as well
prohibiting people from pointing out
when lgbt activists are engaging in
grooming
an article in the leftist online rag the
daily dot echoed these calls claiming
that
the groomer label is fueling an
escalation in quote hateful attacks
against lgbt people
and we're hearing this claim a lot but
there's this this rise in attacks
against lgbt people which which we're
always told can be traced back to
uh
the the
evil right-wingers like myself using
terms like rumor
now to prove that such an escalation and
epidemic is underway
this article in the daily beast links to
a washington post article which asserts
a surge in anti-lgbtq
threats
and they provide no evidence of this
search but instead linked to another
article
this one a fact sheet compiled by
something called the armed conflict
location and event data project
the fact sheet announces that anti-lgbt
plus mobilization is on the rise in the
united states so we begin to see
how the game of leftist telephone works
this is really important because this is
we hear so much about misinformation
well this is how misinformation really
works most of it comes from the left
so you have one article
claiming an escalation and anti-lgbt
attacks
and they cite an article which claims an
ant which claims escalations and
anti-lgbt
threats which in turn cites an article
which claims anti-lgbt mobilization
so we go from mobilization to threats
to attacks
and they all source themselves back to
the same source
they're all citing the same thing
you see as the propaganda filters
from one organ to the next it becomes
more dramatic more dire sounding
and as for this anti-lgbt mobilization
which again serves as the basis for the
claim that anti-lgbt attacks are on the
rise
we're told by this group here that
mobilization refers to
any demonstrations violent or peaceful
also any political violence or any
propaganda activity such as passing out
flyers
so if this group
decides that your peaceful demonstration
is anti-lgbt so for example and they say
later in the article that much of this
is happening in florida so if you
attended a rally a peaceful rally in
support of the anti-groomer bill in
florida then you are lumped in here you
are part of the rise of uh of anti-lgbt
attacks even though you didn't attack
anybody
it only took two links
to turn flyers and peaceful
demonstrations into violent attacks
but in following this thread of
misinformation we've lost sight of the
point which is part of the point of
misinformation to begin with is to make
you lose sight of what you really should
be talking about
the claim is that these violent attacks
which are almost completely fictional to
begin with are fueled by people
criticizing lgbt activists for grooming
and so you shouldn't be allowed to use
the word anymore the left says
which they don't prove that either
so they claim that there are all these
attacks happening can't prove that and
they also claim that these attacks which
are unproven and mostly fictional are
fueled by people saying the word
grooming and that's not proven either
it only took a few days of pressure for
facebook and tick tock to announce that
they too had banned the term and then
twitter followed suit most recently
yesterday the author james lindsay was
locked out of his account and suspended
for tweeting the phrase okay groomer
that got him suspended now
just like that groomer is on par with
uh the n-word
it's a word so vicious and harmful and
hateful that it can't even be written
much less spoken
and why are they so afraid
of the word
well because it's true
the label has power
because it has the force of truth behind
it
the word correctly and succinctly
captures and describes
the left's campaign to sexualize the
youngest generations
there is
nothing these people hate more than the
truth
nothing that scares them more than the
truth
they have no recourse in the face of the
truth they have no defense against it
they have no argument they have no
rebuttal
they can do nothing
when confronted with the truth except
try to
silence it
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well yesterday we discussed the massive
news uh laying bare yet another big
pharma scam and i would say and this is
quite a statement but
uh
the greatest big pharma scam of all time
i think when you look at the um
the numbers involved the money they've
made off of it and the damage caused
uh it is again it's saying a lot because
there are a lot of them but i think this
is this is the greatest the biggest big
pharma scam of all time
and that is the claim that depression
is uh is rooted in a chemical imbalance
in the brain and that is the basis upon
which
millions and millions of americans for
decades have been prescribed
antidepressants in order to cure this
chemical imbalance and now we find out
that um
well that it's that depression has
nothing to do with a chemical imbalance
it was a myth a fiction
a at best a guess
a guess that was made decades ago
and then glommed onto
by
institutions like big pharma because
they could profit off of it
now i say this is kind of there's an
important follow-up in the daily mail
today because i i say that well we just
found out well it was just revealed that
the chemical imbalance theory was is
false that's not actually true it was
not just revealed this has actually been
known for a long time
so it's it's much worse than maybe we
make it sound when we say that this this
just came out now
because then maybe big pharma has an
excuse they could say well we didn't
know
then we could blame them for not doing
their due diligence not doing enough
research but then maybe they could your
ignorance i could say we really didn't
know we thought it worked
well no actually for decades it has been
known that the chemical imbalance theory
is not correct
the daily mail has this uh psychiatrists
have been aware for years that low
serotonin levels may not cause
depression despite continuing to
prescribe the pills a chair of
psychology has said dr jonathan raskin
from state university of new york told
dailymail.com he'd been concerned that
the theory that depression was caused by
low serotonin levels was incomplete for
a while he said many medics continued to
prescribe the medication even while they
were unsure if they were effective
because it was easier than offering more
time intensive care
the pills could still uh help some
patients he added but they're not a
cure-all for those suffering from
depression this week a landmark uk study
called into question society's ever
growing reliance on antidepressants like
prozac um
and uh so then it reviews the study
which we need to go over again
but the point is that this has been
known by by the psychiatrist depression
is a complicated issue and the idea that
we would be able to reduce it simply to
serotonin is not right when we give
antidepressants we don't do this based
on bio biological tests showing they
don't have enough serotonin
but if we think it could help them
ask whether asked whether people should
should keep taking the pills he said i
think that this is a conversation worth
having i'm not going to say people
should or should not be on them but i
think there has been a lot of popular
dissemination of the idea that we have
reduced depression to low serotonin
levels
so this has been known
speaking of what people have known for
years
there's an article in the scientific
american 11 years ago okay back in 2011
this is what was published
it says in a new york times essay in
defense of antidepressants peter kramer
professor of psychiatry at brown insists
that antidepressants work ordinarily
well on a par with other medications
doctors prescribe
kramer's article seeks to rebut a wave
of negative coverage of anti-presence
most notably a two-part essay in the new
york review of books by marsha engel
former editor of the new england journal
of medicine and now a lecture in social
medicine harvard angle cites research
suggesting that antidepressants may not
be any more effective than placebos for
treating most forms of depression
angle highlights a meta-analysis carried
out by the psychologist irving kirsch of
trials of a half-dozen popular
antidepressant submitted by drug
companies to the fda many of the studies
were never published because they failed
to yield positive results
let's stop there for a second
these were studies that failed to yield
positive results and so they just didn't
publish them
and when we say positive results we mean
results that affirm the effectiveness of
antidepressants
they were not able to affirm it confirm
it and so they just didn't publish the
studies
after analyzing all the fda studies
kirsch concluded that placebos are 82
percent as effective as antidepressants
according to kirsch this difference
vanishes if antidepressants are compared
to active placebo placebos which are
compounds
that block certain nerve receptors and
cause dry mouth and other symptoms that
have distinct side effects
this is 2011 again
over a decade ago
it was it was known and being published
that when you put an antidepressant up
against a placebo
there is almost no difference
and then the difference goes away
completely with active placebos and
what's why does the active placebo
matter well because if they give you you
know if you give someone just basically
a sugar pill but it has certain
compounds in it that causes a side
effect dry mouth something like that
then they're going to really feel like
oh well this thing is working and then
they're going to convince themselves
that they feel better and now they do
feel better
that was published 11 years ago but it
was known much sooner than that
the fda knew it but the studies weren't
published because it didn't help big
pharma
this is why i say this is one this is
the greatest big pharma scandal of all
time it's a massive scandal
they're prescribing these drugs with
with by the way the drugs that they're
giving out are not sugar pills
these are dangerous highly potent
psychotropic drugs
with serious side effects
including
uh including
suicide
these are mind-altering substances
substances that
big pharma was giving out
knowing that they didn't work
or at the very least they didn't work
the way they claimed they were working
and now you could just give sure you
could actually give sugar pills to at
least 82 percent of these people and
they would feel the same
i'm hoping this is a red pill moment uh
for
lots of people
you
know about big pharma and also the
psychiatric industry
the ultimate red pill moment is to
realize
that the whole basis of modern
psychology is built on a flawed
understanding of human nature because
i've been talking about big pharma and
implicating them but it's not just them
yeah big pharma is out there making the
billions and trillions of dollars but um
how are the drugs getting prescribed
big pharma is the the system the meat
grinder that people are being fed into
the wood chipper that they're being
thrown into but uh who's who's doing
who's picking people up and toss them
into it psychiatrists
doctors
and we'll know that we're really getting
somewhere we start to question
the
the fundamental basis
of so much of modern psychiatry because
the idea is that
that we hear from psychiatrists is that
there is a baseline sort of normal
desirable
healthy personality and disposition and
emotional and mental makeup for the
human person and that this baseline is
knowable and enforceable and that
everything that falls outside of the
baseline is a disease
and it's a disease in the same way no
different from how cancer or diabetes is
this disease and can be treated the same
sort of way
the the claim is that the human mind not
just the brain but but the mind
okay which is your consciousness your
your conscious experience
can be sick
in the same way that a physical part of
your body is sick
and that psychiatrist in the
pharmaceutical industry have the ability
to determine
what is the right sort of conscious
experience and through drugs they can
heal your conscious experience and make
it go from wrong to right
there are so many
embedded assumptions in all of that like
how do you know any of this who are you
to say
how could how can you take a drug that
heals your mind all of these questions
that aren't even asked
the daily mail article yesterday said
that 90 of the public thinks that the
the
chemical imbalance theory is correct
even though as we talked about yesterday
if you've done just a little bit of
research you would have known before
this article came out that the chemical
imbalance theory is unsupported
and before doing the research you could
have thought about it and realize that
like it doesn't really make sense anyway
you know one other thing i that i've
been hearing over the last 24 hours is
that um
people saying well
you know even if the drugs don't work
the way that they said that the drugs
work it still works right uh
i take it and i feel better
but are you okay with that
you're okay with taking a drug
where
the people giving it to you
don't really know what it does
or how it works
it affects your mind
and they don't really know how it
affects your mind
and the ways that they said it
will work are wrong because they lied to
you
but it makes you feel better so you take
it anyway i mean that's an individual
choice i'm not telling you to take it or
not to take it
but if it were me i'd be very
uncomfortable
be very uncomfortable with
that like if you
this is me with and i'm and i confess
maybe i'm different from a lot of people
i feel this way about all medication not
that i don't take it but i just
before i put anything in my body before
i take any kind of medicine at all i
need to know like everything about it
and i want to know about all the side
effects and i want to start thinking to
myself
you know whatever i'm trying to treat
right now is it worth the potential side
effects and like sometimes it is so it's
like i never take it medicine but i i
just i'm always kind of
skeptical
and so if someone gave me something
that's going to affect my mind and then
i said well how does this work and they
said i don't know
i'm not taking that
that's me
also as just reviewed it it actually
doesn't seem to work like there's very
good evidence that it that it simply
does not work at all
you know if it if it can barely beat a a
a sugar pill in a trial then that's an
indication that it actually doesn't work
what's working is your mind actually
like you you've you've you believe that
you're going to feel better and so you
do that's your mind doing the work it's
not the pill
and it's a very difficult thing to judge
anyway
if it works or not because when when we
say well it works what do we mean we
mean um
well i feel better
but do you feel better because of the
chemicals in the pill
which would be the pill working or do
you feel better because of your belief
about the pill
or maybe because of lifestyle changes
you've made alongside of taking the pill
or maybe because of the therapy that
you're getting alongside the pill like
how do you know that it's the pill
working
these are all interesting questions
um that we should be asking and should
be talking about because the the second
thing that i've heard quite a bit over
the last 24 hours and really going back
for as long as i've been talking about
these issues which i have been talking
about since for as long as i've been on
the public any kind of public stage
the other thing is that well this is
irresponsible and reckless we shouldn't
be talking about this at all
even if the pills don't work even if
it's all based on on a lie
don't talk about it because people will
get off the pills and then they'll and
then and then they'll harm themselves
and so you just shouldn't talk about it
is that how we should treat people
discourage them from thinking about
things not talk about the truth around
them because the truth might
compel them to do something that hurts i
mean this this is this is the way our
so-called public health authorities
treated covet if you recall lied to
about about to us about so many things
kept the truth away from us
because they wanted us to act in a
certain way and they had judged that the
way they want us to act is the correct
way and it's best for us and so they're
going to tell us whatever they need to
tell us to get us to act that way and
they're going to withhold whatever
information they need to withhold
to get us to act that way
but with kovid when we in the public
found out about all the different ways
that we've been lied to and all the
things that were kept from us everybody
was was was uh was outraged
and said no we have a right to know the
truth
yeah with psychiatric medication it's
there a lot of people say no you know
what actually keep lying to me i don't
want to know keep lying to me
all right
let's move to this
all right this is from redux it says a
trans-identified male who used his own
seven-year-old daughter to make sadistic
child sex abuse material has quietly
been transferred to the edna mahan
correctional facility
for women in new jersey on may 6 marina
volsborn matthew was sentenced to 25
years on charges of human trafficking
aggravated sexual assault conspiracy and
endangering the welfare of a child
his charges that stemmed from a 2019
investigation into his conduct after the
new jersey department of child
protection became aware that he was
creating pornography in a home where a
child resided
at the time a search warrant had been
executed at his property after it was
found that the child his own
seven-year-old daughter
had likely been exposed to sexually
explicit material
and summarizing it turns out that it was
much worse than that she wasn't just
exposed to material she was included in
it um she was being sexually abused on
camera
and this was a
a home
where this seven-year-old
girl lived
in unimaginable
i mean being tortured in just
unimaginable ways and she lived
alongside
four men two of which identified as
females
and the two ones that identify as women
marine evolves we just heard another one
ashley romero
so they were all arrested
sent to prison
and um
immediately at least one of them was
sent to a woman's prison
and then marina vols who is the the
father of this girl
uh i guess originally was sent to
a male prison where he belongs
but then was quietly transferred to a
female prison
so here this is a
as the headline says sadistic violent
sexual predator
who is guilty of victimizing his own
daughter
and exploiting her and turning her into
a
sex slave trafficking her
you know she's the child's a guilt a
victim of sex trafficking at the hands
of her own father
and you're gonna take this guy and put
him into a cell with women
all at the behest and why is this
happening
it's all at the best of trans activists
of course in order to not hurt their
feelings
this is what we are supposed to accept
that the self perception
the um
emotional affirmation
of trans people is so important
is so crucial
should be should be such a priority in
fact should be our number one priority
to the extent
that
in service to that self-perception we
will put
sex violent sex offender males in prison
cells with women
so you had this that poor seven-year-old
girl who was sexually tortured for who
knows how long
and
as a punishment we're gonna take this
this pedophile this creep this monster
this animal and we're gonna put him in a
cell with another woman who he can also
sexually torture
all right i'll try to
find something a little bit lighter this
is although not not much more this is a
a new station in new mexico new mexico
had a segment
with a quote local hr expert named
heather and they were talking about
pronouns and how important it is to use
pronouns in the workplace
let's watch some of that
pronouns in the workplace do you know
what your co-worker prefers well joining
me today is heather talamonte founder of
tell us about yourself inc thanks so
much for joining us this morning
good to have you back so first off let's
talk about dei in the workplace and
that's better known as diversity equity
and inclusion how do we go about the
discussion of pronouns so essentially
the employee will reach out and say hey
this is my preferred pronoun this is how
i would like to be
addressed in the workplace how we go
about it is by respecting the request
right so you want to make sure when they
say this is what i would like to be
referred to
we address it and we we honor that and
we
moving forward use that term whether
it's he she
they them their whatever they would like
to use we want to make sure we honor
that request and make them feel
comfortable in the workplace is it
appropriate for someone to ask what
someone's preferred pronoun usages are
you probably wouldn't want to ask that
person would ask you okay so you know if
you um if they haven't fully made the
decision on what pronoun they would like
to use
let them come around to that decision
and then ask
if they haven't asked yet it's not safe
to assume we don't want to make any
assumptions right so this is going to
have
make people be more patient or have to
be patient you do you have to be patient
if you are the employee that is asking
for a new preferred pronoun or pronoun
that's not necessarily natural for
individuals yet
just be patient as they learned to use
the new pronoun or to address you by
that pronoun
yes be uh be patient with me that is
very important you know if i'm working
with you and you have a new pronoun you
want to use
uh that's the only thing i would ask is
is personally please be patient with me
and in fact i would have to
bid that you be very patient indeed
because you'll be waiting forever
for me to respect your stupid pronouns
so you're going to be very very patient
you'll be gonna be waiting until you die
for me to care or respect your pronouns
because i never will
ever
it's not gonna happen
well it's it's it's what makes them
comfortable you know it makes them
comfortable
this is what we've talked about before
the one of the worst things about this
is that
uh it one of the things that frustrates
me so much and sickens me so much
is that
in
spreading this pronoun madness one of
the ways that the left's been able to do
it is by exploiting
in other people what are
good traits like people are like they
like they try to people most people like
to be polite they most people want
others around them to be comfortable
and these in most situations that's a
positive trait
it's the advantage that i have is that i
don't share that positive trait so i
don't care about being polite
and i also really don't care if
you're
comfortable or not like it's that's just
it's not my
it's i don't live my life worrying about
that as far as i'm concerned it's up to
you to make yourself comfortable i don't
how's that my
concern so that's always been my
approach and that's why i've always been
less susceptible to this
but other people are are nicer and so
they they are
can be easily exploited
yeah we talked so much about how
cowardice has led to the proliferation
of gender ideology and cowardice is a
big part of it
but i'm also willing to accept that for
you know a certain number of people
who initially went around along with the
pronoun stuff wasn't so much cowardice
as just they they just were trying to be
nice
and they probably didn't think about it
that much and
but then how quickly do they take
advantage of your
niceness
um
and turn it into this
which is why i know it doesn't come
naturally to a lot of people and again
it's probably good if it doesn't come
naturally to you but we in order to
survive in this culture
and also to
retain and fight for
any semblance of sanity and moral
decency you're gonna everyone needs to
have a little bit of a harder edge
and you gotta get used to saying to
people
who who tell you that what would make
them comfortable what would make them
happy you have to get used to saying to
them i don't care
that's your problem
no ill will
you know go off and try to be
comfortable and happy
but it's not my concern
all right a little bit more from this uh
segment with the
hr she's an hr expert i don't know if
she actually works works in hr
this is like i thought the worst thing
possible is to work in hr but she's
found one level that's even worse to be
you don't work in hr you're just you're
an hr expert outside of hr
um you are the hr for hr
we'll watch a little bit more of this
also if as you're learning to address an
individual by a pronoun you can always
just use their first name can't go wrong
with their first name right so
colton
is over there right right colton will be
here soon so you don't have to use a
pronoun at all if you're not you know
familiar with it if it feels unnatural
what if someone is refusing to use
someone's preferred pronouns and this
will happen i will be very honest in the
workplace this will happen we have
feelings about the pronoun we don't
agree with it so we don't know why we
have to use it
so it's important if you don't agree
to still just use their first name this
isn't something that would rise to the
occasion of getting written up if you
refuse to use it but this could rise to
the occasion of bullying that person may
be repeatedly asking you
this is how i would like to be referred
so it
it wouldn't rise to the occasion of
getting written up but it but it would
be bullying and then bullying gets
written up so ultimately you're still
going to get written up i do want to
clarify one thing because this is
important she says that
she allows
right she's willing to she has grace
enough to admit that um
there will be people who refuse to use
the pronouns if you can believe it dear
god there are people out there who
refuse to use them and and because they
have feelings they have feelings about
your pronouns
and and they have their own feelings and
their own opinions about it and they're
against it
well i want to clarify one thing as one
of the people who will absolutely refuse
to use your pronoun
it's not so much that i have feelings
about your pronoun i actually i cause
i'm not thinking about your pronouns at
all so it's hard i don't
i don't generate any feelings about them
because i'm not thinking about them
okay um i don't have enough
it's to say i have an opinion about i
don't have an opinion either about it
it's not an opinion like if you're a man
then you're a he that's not an opinion
it's just a fact
as far as feelings aren't a lot of
feelings about it i don't go around have
thinking about what's their pronoun this
is how i feel about that i just don't i
just don't care see so you
are coming to me
you're the one with the feelings you're
the one who cares and you are coming to
me and and asking me to do something
and so it's not up to me to justify
myself
it's not up to me to have feelings about
it to explain my quote opinion or
anything like that
i have lived my whole life calling men
he women she and and because that's what
you do and that's just and that's that's
how i've lived my life
you're coming to me with a request and
which is really a demand
telling telling me to change telling
telling me what you want me to do so
it's up to you
to explain why i should
the burden is on you
give me one good reason
so as always they're they say they're
trying to flip it around
where we have to justify ourselves
if we want to continue simply living in
reality where men and our men and women
are women then we have to justify
ourselves
but it doesn't work that way i don't
have to justify anything you have to
justify
so if you're a man coming to me saying i
need you to call me call me a she why
should i do that
now i'm i'm listening i'm sitting i'm
standing right here in front of me like
i'm not going to run away screaming
if you have a really great argument
if you have something you could present
that would make me abandon everything i
know about reality and the rules of
grammar then i'm all ears go ahead and
tell me
but all you have is well make me feel
better oh okay
it wouldn't make me feel better to
abandon reality so
and we're talking about what i'm doing
here not what you're doing so why would
i do that
all right
as we've we've talked a little bit about
the
unintended consequences the trade-offs
you know when it comes to uh efforts by
the climate alarmists and the
environmentalists
to supposedly save the planet here's
another one this one the daily wire says
a law to conserve a species of fish may
have inadvertently led to a recent
uptick in shark attacks in the state of
new york experts interviewed by the new
york post said that sharks are returning
to the waters off long island sound
because of a boom in the population
of atlantic menhaden i think that's how
you pronounce
this the species of fish which is a
species of fish native to the area that
means sharks have been approaching long
island beaches and the process have been
coming dangerously close to it in some
cases biting beachgoers
uh and there have been
according to the executive director of
the south fork natural history museum
shark research and education program the
reason why people are interacting with
sharks more often this year and more
than last year is because of the con
conservation efforts
um
and i think it said there have been
i say there have been six beachgoers who
have been victim to shark attacks
already so far this summer in new york
by the way i love that euphemism
for
and i like that there are people out
there doing some pr cover
for sharks by saying it's an interaction
very well i had an interest i had an
interesting interaction with a shark
today
then you show your bloody stump of a leg
now you might expect that my take here
will be that uh the fish conservation
was a bad idea
because now humans are suffering from
shark attacks because of it
but
i'm gonna surprise you and say no that's
actually not my opinion
that's not my take because if the reason
is that it's hard for me to sympathize
with shark attack victims at all
because
the act of getting into the ocean
is such a strange thing to me
it's it's one of the strangest behaviors
that humans engage in
is to get into the ocean
you've got this massive
vat of water
hundreds of feet deep pummeling the
shore violently with with waves
this deep dark salty pool of death
filled with man-eating monsters and
other other beasts unknown to us
we don't even know everything that's
down there we just know that it's
hideous and monstrous looking
and you're floating around you have all
of that
death underneath you
it's impossible to know exactly what's
lurking under the surface
and our response is to get into it
and then the worst are people that like
if you're if you're if you surf or
something then i can
it's not my thing but okay that's a
recreational activity i can sort of
understand it does look sort of fun
to do but most people who get into the
ocean they don't even do anything they
just kind of like
stand there and let the salty water
pummel them in the face for 45 minutes
and then they get out
it's a very odd behavior so you are look
when you get into the ocean you are you
are getting in this is where the sharks
live this is their home
they can't live anywhere else in
fairness to them
so uh you are entering into the home you
are knocking on the door of mr shark and
saying may i come in and that's
when you look at it like that it just
doesn't make a lot of sense all right
let's get now to the comment sections
[Music]
stephanie says i was a mental health
nurse for 45 years and you can't imagine
the amount of people treated for normal
reactions to wife what life throws at
you i don't take medication and will
never take it unless there is no other
alternative and my life is in danger
um
a powerful statement coming from as you
say a mental health nurse and that's my
that's my approach to medication as well
and i also that also applies to
antidepressants and psychiatric
medication
like i said yesterday i'm not i'm not
claiming that there's never an occasion
where someone should be should take a
psychiatric medication i'm not saying
that
i think that there are occasions where
that would be necessary as a band-aid
okay when you're dealing with someone
who
who is in especially imminent danger to
harm themselves
you have to give them this or they're
going to do something something drastic
they're going to hurt themselves or
somebody else
um that would be an occasion to give
medication because then then it's just
you got to do what anything you can do
to do whatever is necessary
to help that person in that moment but
it is a band-aid it is not a cure
it's not even really a treatment plan
it's something that you do temporarily
and then you transition
to lifestyle changes
therapy counseling all of those things
all together
so that's how i i can see it and um
it's it
and i think there are some people that
many people that will basically agree
with that and then say well so it's a
problem of over diagnosis no it goes far
beyond over diagnosis
when you've got what was it yesterday 65
million people on psychiatric medication
that's not just over diagnosis okay 65
million over diagnosis is really
understating the problem
and it's not just over diagnosis it's
also misdiagnosis
faulty diagnosis
and treatments that are given that uh
on a faulty basis as we've seen
sphere music full says i tried an ssri
antidepressant it made me severely ill
to the point where i believed i was
having
serotonin syndrome aka poisoning by
antidepressants i told the doctor and
she got mad at me and seemed to think
that i needed to push through terrible
side effects never went back to her
again i've heard so many stories like
this
doctors psychiatrists that they put you
on the pill
very quickly and they actually get
frustrated and upset if you try to get
off of the pill
and why do they do that well there's a
financial motive but also it it is
simply easier we heard that from
the psychiatrist interviewed in the
daily mail it's easier to give people a
pill
than to sit down and talk to them trying
to work through their problems you might
think that that's what that's what
you're supposed to do if you're in the
mental health industry
but no for a lot of these people they
want to give you the pill and then move
on a lot easier for them a lot less work
and and you know less training needed
less
less
skill involved really no skill involved
so that's the incentive
um
pam says
matt hit it right on the net hit it
right on the nail my daughter was
bullied at school for calling someone by
their wrong pronouns even though she
didn't know what the heck the person's
pronouns were she was also asked to
state her pronouns in every single class
every single day
needless to say she hated school and i
pulled her out as soon as i could and
now homeschool
um
well that's you did the right thing
so she had to state her pronouns in
every class every day
i don't know why i'm surprised by that
but i actually am a little bit i didn't
know it was quite that bad
every time i think that i've i've kind
of got the gist of it how bad things
have gotten i find out that it's even
worse than that
um
toxic 373 says reminder tom cruise was
right when he scolded matt lauer on the
today show about psychiatry and
antidepressants he actually was right
let's go back uh because you you mention
it
let's go back and remember this was tom
cruise back in i think it was like 2004
or five this was this was a while ago it
was over 15 years ago
and he had this conversation with matt
lauer and on the today show
about psychiatry and psychiatric
medicine and depression and he has been
mocked ruthlessly for this ever since
but it turns out he was 100 right let's
watch that again
here we are today where i talk out
against drugs
and psychiatric abuses of electric
shocking people okay against their will
of drugging children with them not
knowing
the effects of these drugs do you know
what adderall is do you know ritalin do
you know now that ritalin is a street
drug
do you understand that the difference is
this was not against her will though
this wasn't asking your question matt
i'm asking a question i understand
there's abuse of all of these things no
you see here's the problem you don't
know the history of psychiatry i do all
it does is mask the problem matt and if
you understand the history of it it
masks the problem
that's what it does
that's all it does
you're not getting to the reason why
there is no such thing as a chemical
imbalance and i'm saying that drugs
aren't the answer that these these drugs
are very dangerous they're mind altering
antipsychotic drugs and there are ways
of doing it without that so that we
don't end up in a brave new world yes
there are abuses and yes maybe they've
gone too far in certain areas maybe
there are too many kids on ritalin maybe
electric shocking kid's unrelenting that
i'm just saying but but aren't there
examples where it works
you don't even you're glib you don't
even know what ritalin is if you start
talking about chemical imbalance you
have to evaluate and read the research
papers on how they came up with these
theories matt okay that's what i've done
you go and you say where's the where's
the medical test where's the blood test
that says how much ritalin you're
supposed to get
your it's very impressive to listen to
you because clearly you've done the
homework and and you know the subject
and you should and you should do that
also because just knowing people who are
on ritalin isn't enough
that uh
he
couldn't be more right about everything
that he said
and what he says there at the end though
well just because you know someone on
this drug and you say it works and
that's that's not enough to declare that
the drugs should be prescribed or that
they work
but that has always been their response
right you what matt lauer that matt
lauer i thought did a very good job of
playing the role of the kind of hapless
uh uninformed person
who has dipped their toe into this issue
and has a lot of annex has a few
anecdotal stories and then main and then
and then kind of goes along with the
mainstream narrative because of it
he's playing that role you know
uh convincingly because that's who he
actually is and was it still is
presumably
but everything you heard from matt lauer
in that exchange is like i've heard the
same thing so many times over the years
you you make all these points you have
data and research about the the
medicines that these the so-called
medicines that the pharma pharma is
giving out
um about the psychiatric industry the
way they go about these these issues
you you have your criticisms that are
well thought out based in research
based on the data and then what you
always get in response is yeah but i
know someone
i know someone who felt better with it
and then well it might be over diagnosed
but certainly
and then you you hand what you just by
by say by with the
acknowledgement that it might be over
diagnosed you hand wave away 65 million
people on psychiatric medication
and tom cruise again has been
mocked for that ruthlessly ever since he
was 100 right
now
tom cruise is a scientologist
and as people have pointed out online
over the last day or two
that well this doesn't vindicate tom
cruise because he's a scientologist
and his criticism of psychiatry are
rooted in scientology
and the part that he doesn't say is that
yeah modern psychiatry is flawed you
shouldn't take these drugs you should be
a scientologist instead that's the part
he doesn't say in the interview but he
had but that's what he means that's
where he's leading to
and you might be right about that in
fact you probably are now he is a
scientologist and yeah okay so you're
right about that
it doesn't change the fact that what he
says there is true
and the fact that the kooky crazy
scientologist
has more insight
into this issue
and makes more sense
than most other people talking about it
the fact that the scientologist makes
more sense than most of the
psychiatrists and big pharma executives
on this issue um
that's not embarrassing
for those of us who agree with tom
cruise that's embarrassing for the rest
of you
that tom cruise is smarter than you on
this
on this subject
like if you disagree with tom cruise on
that and then and and tom cruise is
vindicated you you should you should
really look at yourself and and and ask
yourself well how did the scientologist
get this right and i didn't
that should be the wake-up call
we're coming up on the first month
anniversary of the launch of daily wire
plus which is a huge milestone we've
already outlasted cnn plus you know so
we could at least have that going for us
and we couldn't have done it without you
so uh pat yourself on the back for that
well done if you're wondering what to
watch this weekend then here's our top
three choices you can start with my
documentary what is a woman if you
haven't already seen it or if you have
seen it go ahead and watch it again then
in honor of his impending retirement
learn all about the person behind the
mask the most successful failure in
government history in fouchy unmasked
and for a pallet cleanser join ben for
ben shapiro's book club filmed in israel
as he explores leon eris's historical
novel and international bestseller
exodus the compelling story of an
american nurse and israeli freedom
fighter and the rebirth of a nation
that's just the tip of the iceberg
there's so much to watch over at
dailywireplus.com so head there now
become a member and get 35 off your new
membership that's
dailywireplus.com today now let's get to
our daily cancellation
[Music]
as we've seen democrats have enormous
difficulty defending abortion in and of
itself or explaining why the average
american should panic over the fact that
women in some states will no longer be
able to have their babies legally
dismembered and that's why in wake of
rose termination
they've embarked on a desperate and
far-reaching campaign
to change the subject they've said that
the end of roe is somehow a threat to
quote-unquote marriage equality they've
said that it's even a threat to
interracial marriage somehow and they
also claim that the end of roe will make
it more difficult or even impossible
for people to access contraception
on that final note the house of
representatives yesterday in response to
the phantom threat to birth control
voted on the right to contraception act
the measure passed with a big assist
from an all-star lineup of the most
useless republican squishes to ever walk
the earth a group of eight headlined as
always by liz cheney adam kinzinger and
nancy mace
all of these uh spineless lumps of
sentient sludge
hopped on board
in an effort to protect access to birth
control
we've of course been told for many years
that women are having trouble accessing
contraception
but where are these women with access
problems i mean where do they live
exactly the sahara desert the moon
because if they live anywhere in
civilization they are surely only a few
miles away from contraception at any
given moment
so if it's that important to you you can
rest assured if you live in in western
civilization you are never more than
like three miles from some kind of
contraception
and you're zero miles away from the
ultimate contraception which is
abstinence
but you could buy it at gas stations you
can buy it at grocery stores drug stores
walmart target rite aid walgreens cvs
you can get it for free at many medical
clinics you can have it delivered to
your door
many of the women who've complained
about this live in cities they live in
cities where they're just
you know you can you don't you don't
have to walk more than 15 steps to find
birth control
birth control practically rains from the
sky in our country and i have no doubt
that if it did literally rain from the
sky to the sky like mana
still the left would complain about
their inability to access it the simple
act of bending down each morning to pick
up the contraception bundles that are
spread across the grass like dew
will be too much of a burden to bear
until free contraception is literally
placed directly in the hands of each
american every day there will be a
crisis of contraception access
and we're going to need bills like this
one to address the mythical problem
but just because this is a messaging
virtue signal bill passed in response to
a non-existent threat and intended to
solve a problem that doesn't exist that
doesn't mean the bill would do nothing
right on the contrary the legislation
would and is designed to
supersede the religious freedom
restoration act abolishing conscience
rights and religious freedom where this
issue is concerned and declaring birth
control including drugs that induce
abortion
a constitutional god-given right
as john mccormick in the national review
writes the democrats right to
contraception act explicitly condemns
state conscience laws that protect
health care providers who refuse to
offer contraception as representative
kathy morris rogers ranking member of
the energy and commerce committee
pointed out on monday the bill was
introduced last friday and bypassed the
usual committee process where several
troubling aspects of the bill could have
been thoroughly debated for example the
bill undermines laws that protect minors
which means that um under this extreme
agenda a planned parenthood
can use taxpayer dollars to sterilize a
13 year old without her parents
knowledge the text of the bill states
that a person with no minimum age listed
has a statutory right under this act to
obtain contraception and to engage in
contraception and a healthcare provider
has a corresponding right to provide
contraceptives and information related
to contraception
has a corresponding right
right so that means that the planned
parenthood has a right a god-given right
to give contraception to kids
of course democrats they just can't help
themselves but add some grooming into
every bill
then this is a classic democrat tactic
here
respond to the alleged radicalism on the
other side by passing a bill far more
radical than anything the other side
ever proposed or attempted
for her part nancy pelosi said that any
republican who opposes this assault on
religious liberty must not understand
the burrs and the birds and the bees
listen
i ask those who oppose contraception
again do you even know what's going on
in your own families why don't you ask
do we need a session of the birds and
the bees to talk about
why this is important
what's going on here
is the blind
desire to have women
controlled and in servitude such that
they don't even want to know the truth
about family planning and contraception
why yes nancy let's have that talk i
mean i i do think
um some of the basics
of human sexuality probably need to be
reviewed
how are babies made exactly nancy can
you explain that
are babies made when a man and a woman
have sex as i always thought or can they
come about some other way
can two men have sex and then one of the
men ends up pregnant
can the copulation of two women lead to
a pregnancy
that's what your side believes now do
you believe it
oh and while we're on the subject what
is conceived exactly what is that life
form in the womb what do we call it i
mean what species is it
can you answer that is it a is it a
human
life
it seems that the birds and bees
conversation is very complicated over on
your side in fact
and if they can't explain the birds and
the bees then um we can be fairly
confident that they won't be able to
explain concepts that concepts that are
more difficult
like the concept of a human right
because even if you think that birth
control is the greatest thing in the
world
which based on the number of children i
have is clearly not my view
but even if it's yours
you still cannot coherently claim that
birth control is a right
because a right is supposed to be
god-given it's supposed to be ingrained
in our nature as human beings
fundamental to the human condition this
is the concept of rights that lies at
the foundation of our country and it's
what our entire system of government is
based on
if artificial birth control is such a
right
then it would be true that nobody in any
circumstance for any reason would have
the right to refuse to provide it to you
the left says that it is a right because
to them
a right is simply anything they want
if they want it they have a right to it
and that's why whenever you tell them
that they don't have a right to
something
they take it to mean that they cannot
have the thing at all
they don't recognize the distinction
between a want and a right a privilege
and a right a product they desire and a
right
so when you say you don't have a right
to that you're saying i can't have it no
that's that's not the same
that's not that's not the same
they think everything is all right if
they want it
they've sought to reconfigure the whole
notion of human rights in a way that
does not expand our rights actually but
rather limits our rights in favor of
their ever-growing list of want-based
rights
so they abolish rights rooted in human
nature which are actual rights for the
sake of rights rooted in desire
their ultimate goal is a country filled
with
slaves
who possess no fundamental human rights
but who remain satiated because their
desires are met
that's why birth control is so important
to these people especially the ones in
charge
comfortable over sexed overfed vassals
that's what they want us to be that's
their vision
a brave new world in other words
huxley had it right all along
and the
right to contraception act is yet
another step in that direction which is
why it is today cancelled and that'll do
it for us today thanks for watching
thanks for listening have a great
weekend talk to you next week godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by jeff tomlin our
audio is mixed by mike cormina hair and
makeup is done by cherokee heart the
matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin